after all these years is tearing down
statues of historical figures still a
thing the New York City council's
Cultural Affairs committee met today to
discuss taking down historical monuments
honoring Washington Jefferson and
Columbus
yeah because removing historical statues
worked out really well last time cat if
they uh they're discussing this
legislation and uh I thought this whole
thing was over but the real question is
where are the homeless going to urinate
[Laughter]
that's not a question the answer is
wherever they want yes
yes uh also I was reading this article
and it was like okay if they don't want
to take him down then the Department of
Transportation has to consult with the
Department of Education so I actually
don't think they'll ever come down
because the government will just spend a
bunch of money trying to figure out how
to do it and it'll never actually happen
and I also I don't know am I just not
observant but does anybody really spend
that much time looking around like oh
that's statues of that guy like yeah
everyone just looks at their phone
that's true that's true this is like
making a big deal where there is no deal
at all at all you know uh Morgan I mean
without these statues where are New
Yorkers supposed to cover
it stuffed with graffiti I mean yeah
that's where I do it I'm sure that's
what you do after the show yes exactly
absolutely uh the crazy thing about all
of this is that there's even a cultural
Affairs committee I mean this is already
one of the most diverse uh and amazing
cities on the planet and so now you need
this committee how about having a
committee to deal with crime
homelessness uh the millions uh
thousands of migrants that are coming to
the city right
you know I just feel like there's a lot
going on New York that they should be
worried about you know Perhaps Perhaps
those things pay attention to the crime
of the city statues don't rape and Rob
and kill Jamie they don't even move
that's right except for in this one
nightmare I had
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and like
is the point like what is this really
gonna do like Washington he's also on
the dollar bill yes right like close all
the strip clubs
okay
I was thinking about Washington on the
dollar I was just thinking like man I
hope he liked that picture of himself
headshotted me out there once I was like
oh it's everywhere and um
your dollar bills on yeah see I wonder
if you were on the dollar bill you
probably get like laid a ton do you know
what I mean you're just like you're just
like get holding it out like oh who's
that
and Ben Franklin comes up like got
changed for a hundred
he was a that's all I got I think it's a
waste you're right if you're going to
get rid of somebody that you think is
offensive you're right there's probably
30 guys doing heroin surrounding that
statue in Columbus Circle like let's
clean up exactly yeah I mean New York's
problems Tom are plenty you have people
robbing Walgreens pushing women in front
of subways you know shooting up an over
overdosing on your doorstep but this is
the priority yeah the group said that
they want to ban statues for anyone who
owns slaves or benefited from slavery
yeah which is I thought that was me and
everybody else right yeah like these
groups keep saying that we're all that
you know we all benefited from slavery
so that would mean that no one would be
able to have a statue but then the
people from the Columbus group that was
trying to defend Columbus was saying oh
Columbus was a migrant and I'm like oh
now you lost conservatives you know
that's not gonna help don't buy into
their argument you know well then we
should get back the Statue of Liberty
it's from the French they were
colonialists oh yes yeah no that's a
great Point Morgan well I'm smart every
now and then yeah you are
mostly then
that was mean and I don't care hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else